you're watching screen junkie Central
this episode is brought to you by Mafia
3. Family is who you die for
[Music]
what is happening screen junkie Central
thank you for coming down this has been
an insane dream how great screen junkie
Central has been your attendance you're
making our dreams come true and uh let
me just Let's Get Hype when I say screen
Junkies you say Central you ready
screen Junkie
hey Junkies
thank you you guys we are here tonight
for a comedy show that I've been hosting
and producing in Los Angeles for over
seven years this is the tournament of
nerds the craziest most insane comedy
debates you've ever witnessed okay you
know what
yeah they're pretty crazy they're pretty
crazy
um we could not get started without my
co-creator my co-host please put your
hands together make some noise for
Justin Donaldson
hey
hey how Rodney oh Justin what a ride
how's your Comic-Con oh it's been
give me a highlight of your Comic-Con
highlight of my Comic-Con uh you know
I'm a big action figure toy collector
yes you are so the highlight of my
Comic-Con is seeing all the new uh WWE
wrestling figures oh yeah yeah we got
some fans Justin
um how many action figures do you own
thousands literally you have storage
units with only action figures right I
have three 20 by 20 storage units full
of action figures shut the front door
it's a problem
wow and uh Justin I'm excited you've
been to so many Comic Con this is my
27th straight San Diego Comic-Con
um legit legit and they're gonna bury me
under the convention center when I drop
dead here in a couple of years God bless
you
um nerds will sweat on Your Grave so
Justin I'm going to take a second to
explain to these folks what exactly
we're doing today please do what's gonna
happen right here on this stage we have
eight bloodthirsty nerds backstage each
of them is debating on behalf of a pop
culture character we're gonna Whittle
that down from eight to four to two to
one nerd to rule them all oh yeah it's
like a March Madness bracket of Pop
Culture nerdum how does that sound
[Applause]
[__] yeah so
who's judging these debates wow they be
decided we have a panel of Doom a panel
of awesome judges people that know what
they're talking about we're not just
dragging people off the street and
bringing them up here oh no we didn't go
just get some accountant from H R Block
we didn't get a Harley Quinn in a
Deadpool we got actual experts yeah we
have some pretty cool judges we have
four judges and if the judges in there
judging are ever tied to two we're gonna
come to you the audience to decide are
you ready for that
nice uh Justin I think without any
further Ado we should bring out our
judges let's get this started how who is
tonight's panel of Doom first oh he has
judged the tournament of nerds many
times he's a DC writer of Wonder Woman
77 and Batwoman and he's a old friend of
screen junkies Make some noise for Mark
and Draco
mark thank you for being here
um without this man none of us would be
here because he's our biological father
uh he's the creator of screen junkies
and honest trailers Make some noise for
Andy signal
[Applause]
I brought two Mike's Hard lemonades this
is the last show I can get drunk this
guy means business
he may get up to a hard tee by 10
o'clock
you know this next man because he led
the folks on The Walking Dead to
Alexandria please make some noise for
Ross Marquand
[Applause]
[Music]
and you know them you'll love them he's
one of the funniest guys around the host
of Doug Loves movies and the upcoming
screen junkies Plus show pitch off with
Doug Benson it's Doug Benson
[Applause]
what a pro what a Pro won't even drop
the camera to shake hands
guys thank you for being here
you want to go right to it yeah uh
judges are you ready
sure oh Born Ready audience are you
ready
then let's find out what our first
debate of the night is what is it Hal it
is
Dalton from Roadhouse
versus
Gollum
debating for Dalton from Roadhouse
star Joe Starr
[Applause]
and
debating for Gollum Roger
[Music]
[Applause]
wow this is some great cosplay right off
the bat
all right they are going to debate Joe
Starr is going first let's get a minute
on the clock for Joe Starr
Golem's got one rule
get the precious
Dalton's got one rule too
be nice
until it's time
to not be nice
and then when it's time to not be nice I
break your knee and I rip out your
throat because I know
I know I cleaned up my bar and my town
in one movie this guy spent six movies
worth of Lord of the Rings nonsense
trying to steal a cheap ring from two
anemic Smurfs
it's the big bad in this guy's World
Sauron a big flaming eye you know I
fixed that a smile bottle of Visine I
took down Blake Wesley I took down
Wesley I took down Corporate America in
my bar that's right
this guy looks like a Dick's elbow
I look like America
[Music]
time
a minute on the clock is gone
hello can we get more pens hello spring
Junkies
goodbye
what's Comic-Con precious Comic-Con is a
place for nerds done was Chuck Dalton
here I just don't know it doesn't make
any sense all right everyone loves a
Golem impersonation don't they but
listen up here's the fact Golem is
dirtier than anybody here Gollum is a
pure
why because he will go through six
movies just to get that one precious
exclusive that's like waiting in line at
Comic-Con that's what Gollum does he
will win in those lines he's that guy
who gets in the whole age
he gets in there that's what he does yes
and if you think you get poontang you're
in my world now my friend I
time time time
30 second rebuttal round no start Dalton
30 seconds on the clock go all right
buddy let's talk about this hang on let
me do a little what do you want Alicia
Malone
what the [__] guys like you and Chris in
prison oh you want to go you want to go
with Dalton all right let's Tai Chi this
up
now die Alicia Malone sweetly in your
nice dress
I just killed Alicia Malone
time
all right a questionable move
30 seconds on the clock for gone
let's kill us green junkie's favorite
that'll get it for once vote good idea
and look I'm a crazy person I have a
split personality of course I'm gonna
talk weird but you say things like pain
don't hurt you went to college for God's
sakes speaking proper grammar that's
even the wrong contraction
six seconds
four
that's all I gotta say
time Wow Let's Hear It for both of these
guys all right how is it just me or did
that make perfect sense you know what
this is an argument we've talked about
many times
regular debate we would win in a fight
yes classic now we're gonna find out
Mark and Draco talk to us this was tough
they're both great competitors uh but uh
even though I've never seen Roadhouse
when he called Gollum a Dick's elbow I
think that decided it for me so I'm
voting for Dalton
1-0 Dalton Andy signor I have seen
Roadhouse and my God Joe committed there
that coupled with the Dick's elbow it
just put it over the edge for me uh
because I wanted something else from
Roger at the end and it was really good
start they were tied and then I just
thought that that scene was just was
precious
we're all tied up
no I voted for Joe yeah yeah
Andy votes for a screen junkies employee
story at 11.
so glad I voted for him
you're a loser trouble Brewing what are
you Ted Cruz
so the ring is missing why don't you
just look under the couch cushions it
seems silly
Ross
clean Roadhouse and I was in a band in
middle school called Dick's elbow
so my vote is with Dalton Dalton
yeah my vote doesn't count doesn't even
it's not even necessary Roger great
Trump is our president now I I tried to
vote I tried but they wouldn't let me
hey uh just want to say thanks to all
the screen junkies coming out here we
really love it oh nice try nice
[Music]
one let's find out what our second match
of the first round is what is it it's a
doozy that's what it is it's a doozy
please welcome Kingpin
versus the penguin
representing Kingpin Jason Wayne
Christian
[Music]
and
representing the penguin yanoam you love
them Nick Monday
[Applause]
that is bad luck
uh did the penguin smoke American
Spirits they're Parliament
let's get a minute on the clock Jason
Wayne's going first for the Kingpin
go my name is Wilson Fisk I understand
I'm here to compete against one Oswald
cobblepot now Oswald I know you have a
major in Ornithology you're a genius
with a lifelong love of bird so please
tell us what's the genus of the emperor
penguin hey uh I just like some oral
very good
now
Oswald cobblepot was so depressed when
his mother passed away and his favorite
cockatoo was repossessed he gave up
everything he had to devote his life to
crime and [__] emus
I've gone toe-to-toe with Captain
America Spider-Man and Daredevil whereas
you were almost killed by Harvey Bullock
while he was drunk
that's the equivalent of being beaten by
Chris Christie under the Atlantic City
Boardwalk
six seconds
no no no not worth it no
time let's get a minute on the clock for
Nick Monday
okay so when you're looking for a bad
guy right you want a party boy with
trick umbrellas a duck float and someone
who wants to make Gotham great again
you know what an art critic with
Asperger's talking about his daddy
issues all the time okay this guy he his
villain plots are to gentrify Northern
Manhattan guess what Wilson already
happened
I wasn't a kid that firstborn Sons drown
them and run for mayor that's right
mayor I almost was mayor and I'm half
fish how [__] up is that we can't even
get a woman president and I was almost
mayor by the by by the by you can't
you're your hero is a blind [__] dude
who gets a [__] kicked out of him all
the time I have to deal with Batman
the greatest hero in the world and guess
what I even nightclub in Gotham and he
can't do a goddamn thing about it
time all right 30 seconds on the clock
rebuttal round Kingpin going first Jason
Wayne go the reason my hero gets his ass
kicked all the time is standing right in
front of you
[Music]
now
the genus of the emperor penguin by the
way was aptenoditis I think you would
know that considering one of your
henchmen took over your entire criminal
Empire and then named himself the
emperor penguin leaving you painless on
the streets
your success is a crime Lord is I'm sure
as
good as your success on Tinder
all right 30 second rebuttal penguin
Nick Monday Tinder I tendered your wife
Vanessa and I might have fingers but I
got a flipper and I got all the spaces
she gonna get
[Applause]
and you might want to talk about science
or nombo jumbo but man I'm a guy with
hardships who overcomes a lot of stuff
I'm a [__] freak Show and everyone
loves me let me hear it
and guess what I'm gonna go fly away my
goddamn umbrella
right Wow Let's Hear It for these guys
Doug mentioned we didn't get a chance to
go to you last time you're first up this
time what do you think oh my vote's
gonna count this time I'm excited I was
a little insulted because I suffered
from Asperger's
that's why you lie out of your butthole
but I gotta go with that Asperger the
penguin 10. penguin Ross talk to us I
gotta go with Mr Fisk I'm so sorry but I
just it's a compelling argument
I like his style we are locked up in one
one
Andy signor yeah one just made me laugh
more it's really because they were both
strong but that uh I I'm mayor and I'm
half fish
and the fact that he he the Batman
versus Daredevil thing was pretty great
and that last thing with the flipper you
put me over the edge I Gotta Give It To
The Penguin two one and Andy doesn't
even like Mark and Draco I was surprised
no one brought up the Daredevil and
Batman were both the same guy
cinematically at one point that's true
[Music]
spoiler alert but between gentrifying
Northern Manhattan and flipper blasting
Vanessa Fisk I'm going with the penguin
penguinely we will see you in round two
Jason Jason thank you so much Wow Let's
see the third matchup of the first round
What's it gonna be it is
from Ghostbusters the new one Holtzman
verses from Beauty and the Beast Belle
representing Holtzman Cassie Jerkins
[Music]
hey
and representing Bell Joan Ford hi hi
what's up Comic-Con
all right Holtzman vs Bell let's get a
minute on the clock for Holtzman
holtzman's going first hey everybody I
am Jillian Holtzman
Ghostbuster super smart brilliant
scientist Belle I'm so glad your husband
let you out of the house today
I mean that's what Beauty and the Beast
is teaching young women right it is
really about marrying a a handsome man
not a beast he's got to turn into a
handsome man at the end and then you
live happily ever after right oh and you
know we all know that she loves books
right but we do know that that was a
plot device for the Beast to get into
her pants and also for Disney to show
off their new animation right
yeah also your dad's an inventor uh hi
I'm an inventor welcome to 2016.
yes uh what else do I want to say about
beauty oh yeah it's called Beauty and
the Beast not personality and the Beast
uh yeah so I think you know what you
were trying to teach I'm minute on the
clock for Bell Joan Ford go hey guys
who's excited for next Halloween cause
multiply that times 100 and that's a
preview
I'm really happy that like women finally
have their Austin Powers their Ron
Burgundy they're Borat they're
aggressively annoying character they can
impersonate
as opposed to actually being funny
I'm kidding I'm kidding guys I'm really
excited that we have we're in a living
in a world now where women can be
Ghostbusters
do you want to know about it I agree I
agree
do you want to know about a world where
women could not be Ghostbusters
18th century France
women couldn't be Ghostbusters mostly
because go stay confined to inanimate
objects who are Bid who are doing the
bidding of the living but also because
[Music]
Cliffhanger uh that's right uh women can
totally bust ghosts uh I proved that uh
last week uh we're doing okay in the box
office
uh
don't ask me about China or a second
Ghostbusters I don't know if that's
gonna happen but I will tell you one
thing about Ghostbusters women all
different shapes and sizes and not a
super teeny teeny teeny and possibly
tiny waist uh cookie cutter face uh big
eyes Barbie feet and uh no hips
[Music]
the reason women can be Ghostbusters
today is because Brave women in 18th
century fans
chose to read books when it wasn't cool
people talk [__] about her you had to
read them to sheep and the Sheep would
eat the books
but I guess that's what feminism is
today [__] on the women who came
before you sitting on the women who
raise you up so you could be a
Ghostbuster in 2016.
political statements Hal let's have a
round of applause for women
more than enough more than enough all
right uh let's go to Ross Marquan why me
first
eight women I've read it on the internet
that's what it's really about
both compelling arguments you look a lot
like Trey Parker I gotta say that's
pretty big I don't which one that a
compliments
uh that's I just said heads up uh I am
transgender so any kind of like dude
references won't be appreciated oh no no
it wasn't even that just usually like
Trey Parker oh damn anyway
um fans what every woman wants to hear
you look like Trey Parker sorry you're a
beautiful man yes sorry sorry at the
very least rich
confusing uh so I think that I gotta go
with with uh Bell here on this one
honestly because she did pave the road
like she said she paved the road for
these these young women possibly shamed
into it but he's going with Belle
[Music]
one oh Bell
Mark and Draco
he's got really political yeah yeah you
know there was like there was a woman
Ghostbuster body shaming Bell by not
saying she was beautiful and then you
talked about your movie doing okay it
dropped 76 this week
[Music]
wasted no hips being in the new
Ghostbusters Chris Hemsworth
yummy hey
But ultimately I have to vote for the
person who's representing the movie
that's actually good and that would be
Belle in Beauty and the Beast
[Applause]
although tonight I've been like these
are the real people this is really
Gollum
this is really Dalton correct like it's
really the wool's been pulled over my
eyes repeatedly because this is
Comic-Con you never know who's gonna
show up even dead fictional characters
wait is Dalton dead if Patrick Swayze is
dead so my point is I'm sure he's been
killed by now
my point is I never wanted to see Belle
wearing denim so I'm gonna have to go
with the Ghostbuster
[Applause]
yeah look I'm just going strictly on who
was the funniest or closest to the
character gave me those things and I
have to go with Holtzman
we're all tied up
go to the audience
great so let's uh have a round of
applause for both of our ladies
now please only applaud Hoot and Holler
for the one you feel Prevail I'll be
keeping an eye on you was it Belle
[Applause]
was it Holtzman
n
is moving forward
great job
all right that's fine final match up of
course what is it oh this is a good one
oh this one's a dudes oh I have money
riding on this one Anakin Skywalker
versus Zack Snyder's Superman
representing Anakin Skywalker please
welcome to the stage tip chain
[Applause]
Tim you put as much effort into your
costume as you do in life thank you
thank you very much
Anakin Skywalker oh
I thought you were wearing a hoodie
representing Zack Snyder Superman Mike
Carlson
[Applause]
commercial actor Mike Carlson
shut up Tim
how let's get a minute on the clock for
Anakin Skywalker going first Shane go
but soft what light through yonder
window breaks
it is the Anakin Skywalker thou art a
Sith thou art a Jedi neither but a lover
Skywalker is
Superman may have crushed a city in his
battle
but young Annie crushed padme's soul
with words of rattle
Anakin you're breaking my hearts you're
going down a path I cannot follow but
padme's words only continue to be Hollow
Anakin's Soul can truly see what is real
as he spoke the poetic words from my
point of view the Jedi are evil
young Annie's soul but then at his heart
was lost with nowhere to go like all of
us who feel crushed we all scream no
Superman is very very very strong Thou
Art Anakin however
Mike Carlson Zack Snyder Superman
go
first of all I want to congratulate Tim
on completing his Junior College poetry
class
it's great it's a tough class good job
second of all folks I am not arguing for
regular nice Superman I'm arguing for
Zack Snyder Superman a jacked up slow
motion murder machine
he's a guy who fights three villains at
the end of Man of Steel and he kills
like a hundred thousand people it's
crazy okay like yeah Anakin is scariest
power might be the force but Zack Snyder
Superman's scariest power is his
disregard for human life
okay and yeah like he's going to win
he's more dangerous and meanwhile Anakin
is a dope he's a guy who trusted Senator
Palpatine
folks let me give you a piece of advice
if there's a guy who sounds like a
cartoon villain from the 60s like hello
Anakin don't trust him
no don't trust him he's evil for sure
time 30
seconds on the clock for Anakin rebuttal
Tim Chang go
shout out to Mount San Antonio Community
College for those classes
Superman is very very very strong
but Thou Art Anakin however is also very
very strong
is there no shame in killing children is
that so wrong
the Anakin left a bloody trail that was
very long
now our Anakin
30 seconds on the clock for Zack Snyder
Superman Mike Carlson go
folks I can wrap this battle up very
quickly because I know Anakin
Skywalker's number one weakness
sand
okay he hates sand it's coarse it gets
in wherever so like let's say we can
take this battle to the beach
okay he's gonna hate that it's gonna
really bother him say we put on a beach
boys record and they're singing about
sand folks gonna drive him nuts okay and
then bam Superman kills him because yeah
he's a murderer
wow what a barn burner
signor talk to us oh well I was I saw
Anakin come out and it looked very lazy
and I wasn't into that and then I saw
Superman come out with such good effort
look at those muscles
so then I was giving sort of an
automatic first point to Mike but then
uh Tim started talking and was playing
the character of Anakin so lazily I was
like oh it's that he's doing the shtick
I get it now but then he kept going and
I Lady lost it
I was into it so I was and I didn't know
what he was doing Mike ultimately won me
over with uh jacked up slow-mo murdering
machine so Mike uh Superman one oh
Zack Snyder super Ross Marquan Superman
oh Zack Snyder Superman nothing about
your thought processes or anything just
write to Superman
Superman Man uh listen you know Superman
you really had me and then I don't know
what all that talk was about sand at the
end
sand just was a prominent thing in the
response to a poem so whatever beach
towel
what I what I like to judge
by tonight on is how important safety is
at Comic-Con and I like to judge The
Debaters the fighters by how safely they
can cross the street at night and that's
why my vote goes to Superman
Superman moving on Anakin the force is
weak in that thank you that means later
tonight we will see Belle versus Zack
Snyder's Superman yes but first oh it's
time for the second round here we go
returning from the first round Dalton
from Roadhouse in the dream matchup
you've talked about many times before
against the penguin please welcome back
to the stage representing Dalton from
Roadhouse Joe Starr and representing the
penguin Nick Monday so it's just like
materialized yeah I didn't even I was
waiting to give me the big entrance and
then boom there's Joe Starr all right
let's get a minute on the clock for
Dalton from Roadhouse going first
materialized out of thin air just like
Patrick Swayze from Ghost
first of all I'd like to say it's an
honor to be up here with Casual Friday
penguin
the Penguins got a gang the red triangle
gang they are the scariest clowns that
have ever been put in a film
if you are a villain
and your henchmen are scarier than you
you are a shitty villain
if the Red Triangle gang came at me I'd
be fine with it because guess who's got
my back Sam Elliott
I don't like this guy because he's all
about plots and schemes when I see
something you know what I do I reach out
I force it up against a stone wall in a
barn and I [__] it face to face
like a man does
hi made it on the clock for the penguin
make Monday go yeah it's funny uh he's
talking about his friend uh fighting me
uh yeah his friend died you know who
else died the farmer died you know who
else got killed all the trucks and uh
cars getting sold by the car salesman
because my friend Dalton is shitty at
his job and you know what's worse he's a
scam artist and I have a theory that
he's a hobo example one he sucks at his
job he let so many people die explain
that and uh example two he sleeps in a
barn you know who sleeps in a barn hobos
I'm a [__] penguin and I wouldn't
sleep in a uh Barn I sleep at sewers but
not a barn
example three the most standing he hates
when strippers take off clothes because
hobos love clothes and because they keep
them warm and he hates when strippers
take him off because it's a waste and
who hates strippers taking off clothes
some piece of [__] scam artist hobo
also I used to [__] dudes like him in an
aquarium
uh 30 seconds to rebuttal round
Joe start Donald for Morehouse go
first of all I want to make something
clear I'm not a hobo I'm a
semi-professional recording artist
oh no Gollum you're eating you're eating
his body and his time
[Applause]
oh why do they keep making me do this I
just want to move to a new town and know
some peace
your life was good
much like Patrick's Day
and scene
four seconds on the clock rebuttal
around Nick Mundy penguin go you know I
could repeat the same bit again
but I'm not because there's one thing
that Dalton couldn't stop
or cool
cancer
he couldn't stop and then he became a
ghost and he couldn't stop Demi Moore
from getting ravaged by some bad dude he
needed Whoopi Goldberg himself and
anyone who needs Whoopi Goldberg's help
is no cooler in my book and I should
know I'm dependent
wow I'm sorry I ate barn burner man Mark
and Draco
this was very educational I did not know
that hobo slept in bars or that they
loved clothes Barnes Barnes oh and at
first I didn't think you said hobo and I
was gonna get really offended no I'm not
playing that game
uh so it came down to the brilliant line
of Hobo's love clothes but I think it
was trumped early on by Casual Friday
penguin
so I'm gonna have to vote for Dalton
[Music]
is he breastfeeding
foreign
I didn't realize these two were so close
taught me a casual Friday for sure and
then penguin lost me at cancer
yeah because I I'm a Cancer and so
I don't like people bringing up in such
a Negative light
so I mean I gotta go with Dalton two two
oh
Dalton Andy signor
yeah I got it it's just the commitment
there he even got his former competitor
to to do this for him I just I can't
ignore that he's gonna [__] him against
the stone wall shut the [__] they're
totally gonna [__] I gotta help them
[__] Dalton go [__] them
moving on to the finals big round of
applause for Nick Monday everybody
wow look at this commitment this is true
acting this is an actor's craft and Nick
isn't gonna help him one bit
Nick could knock it out of here fast
enough
please drag Roger come on back please
funny kicked him I think Bundy kicked
him
to kick him
dead I mean he killed him why did you
stop why did you stop pulling him all
right we're gonna move on to our second
second round matchup Hal
oh
it is Bell against Zack Snyder Superman
yes it is I will save you the trouble of
looking at your notes thank you please
welcome back to the stage representing
Bell Joan four
and representing Zack Snyder Superman
Mike Carlson
you know what in what Universe could
this take place Warner Brothers Disney
they'll all be won some days there's
gonna be one [__] conglomerate of
characters and [__] and probably
soon probably yeah produced by megacorp
all right let's get a minute on the
clock for Belle goat hey guys hey guys
you ever uh try to read a book to a
sheep
it's [__] hard man
Zack Snyder's Superman would not have
the patience with that [__] okay let's
get down to it uh who here considers
themselves a feminist
about the reaction I expect from the
screen junkies crowd very cool
um
would a feminist allow Holly Hunter one
of our greatest living screen Legends to
drink a jar of piss because Zack
Snyder's Superman allowed that to happen
ma'am you would you allow the star of
Broadcast News to drink a jar of piss
Ed I would like her escorted from the
building
she would let the star abroad I would
not let any member Bell would not let
any member of the Broadcast News crew to
drink a jar of pit Albert Brooks no
I forget who else
minute on the clock Zack sniper Superman
Mike Carlson go uh legitimately does she
drink the jar she just look at it no she
drinks that she like drinks that's a
different discussion all right folks you
brought it all is so I did you're right
I'm sorry Belle is so concerned with
singing and fun and it's totally a waste
of time Superman doesn't even have time
for music the only song he likes is the
sound of innocent civilians being harmed
okay now let's just compare the music in
these movies like it's a little town
every day it's a very nice pleasant
Melody meanwhile Man of Steel it's
I mean who is the scarier thing I mean
who's gonna be more scared of Superman
obviously and the thing is Belle is nice
she's so nice she's not gonna go she's
not doesn't have the Killer Instinct
Superman was raised by two of the
craziest parents that I've ever seen a
cold distant Kevin Costner which four
who forced Superman to watch him be
murdered by a tornado and then in Batman
vs Superman when he's like hey Mom
30 second rebuttal Joan Ford Bell go
Superman is not more callous than Belle
you know what's a fate worse than death
having to dwell within a Candlestick for
all eternity ma'am would you let
somebody live inside a Candlestick for
all eternity
all right security let her stay
Belle is the real monster here she lets
all those servants live in plates and
forks and [__] probably the toilet
there's probably a servant that the
Beast is taking that [__] in
30 seconds on the clock for Mike Carlson
Zack Snyder super hose gross folks
uh look here's the thing a bell is a
nice person and really if we were
talking about her powers like her only
power is to overlook a man's looks okay
because Belle is like a nine or a ten
and then Beast is like a three or a four
and I'm only giving it to him because of
the wealth yeah I'm shallow folks
okay
meanwhile Superman to finish a joke from
earlier he's talking to his mom and he's
like hey I don't know if I should but I
should save all these people and she's
like
Mike I feel like there's a lot of
furries in this town this weekend that
would disagree with you about the Beast
yes we'll see if that plays in Andy
signor wanted our table uh yeah that was
that was tough
um
the one that made me laugh I gotta go
with just when I'm not sure I go with
whatever made me laugh more and it was
Superman uh Superman and she didn't
drink the jar of piss she did 100 she
drank
my life on it all right well I I don't
remember I've watched that movie too
many times uh we're not sure about the
jar of piss yeah
Ross Marquand
Superman
[Music]
she says man every time
Doug Benson uh uh how how what's the
vote so far now it's 2-0 Superman okay
then I go with Belle just to get an
exciting finish
2-1 to keep things excited one two one
Mark and Draco
Mike you're the one that said that
Bell's power is to overlook a man's
looks yes that's what every woman at
Comic-Con is doing
but
bless you all your hero but you the idea
of there being a servant who was turned
into a bidet in Beauty and the Beast has
ruined that movie for me
I know some of you probably are going to
watch it again with that point of view
um so yeah I I have to vote for Superman
Superman moving on
[Applause]
[Music]
our final is Saturday
match up here
in what Universe could this happen
Justin none because no one ever wanted
to see this
but we're gonna see it right here right
now Dalton from Roadhouse versus Zack
Snyder's Superman let's welcome back to
the stage
the Roadhouse Joe Starr
have you have you had the time of your
life
and fresh off his blast around Victory
Mike Carlson Zack Snyder Superman
wow he's back back gentlemen go ahead
and Shake Hands let's shake hands before
we do oh
all right a minute on the clock for
Dalton from Roadhouse go
penguin talked a little bit about cancer
let's bring up cancer
because there's a lot more to Swayze
than Roadhouse I'm also a ghost
because I'm with you all the time
my spirit's faster than a speeding
bullet
I hope you make pots
and unlike this guy there has been a
Superman since Christopher Reeve and his
name is Patrick [__] Swayze
thank you
I have a friend that's a farmer
I run a room from him
cash 200 a month
that's all I need
because I'm American a Superman should
be
who's got a light
three two one
time
a minute on the clock for Zack Snyder
Superman Mike Carlson go folks if we're
throwing the rules out the window here
I'm not only Superman I'm also a Man
from Uncle
the movie we all saw and know very well
and there are many specific points I
could mention but choose not to
all right we're talking Dalton we're
talking Superman here's the thing folks
I know what we like about these dudes
they're hunks
okay these are two hunks so it's gonna
be a hunk fight and yeah he's got a cool
thing going on shirt open 80s thing but
I don't know kind of boring this is
Superman this is Henry Cavill it's AB
Fest all day folks it's AB Fest and not
only that this is a guy who has a beard
a Superman with a beard he's lifting
things this is a hipster Superman he's
ecological ecologically friendly because
it's from solar power okay and this is
also a guy that wants to stop Zod from
gentrifying Earth this is a cool hot
modern Superman for the modern era
unlike this time
30-second rebuttal Dalton from Roadhouse
Joe star go we're both hunks I'll give
you that
but Zack Snyder Superman looks like he
has to take a [__] all the time
I'm loose I always look like I just took
that [__] 10 minutes ago
and I'm ready to back to put you back
against the barn wall
no foreplay
the 80s dad James come off and I'm right
in there
[Applause]
[Music]
when you're completely eliminated or
when you have to take a huge [__] I [__]
in a jack-in-the-box once after eating
an ostrich burger and I could have
punched out an old lady
that's how scary he is because yeah he
does have to take a [__] and also he can
end pretty much any fight just by saying
his own mother's name
or any other one's mother he just has to
go through a list of names and the fight
will probably stop and he'll win time
wow
let's hear it for both of our final
combatants
[Music]
[Applause]
a real barn burner let's start with Doug
Benson I just prefer a more dignified
debate I don't know why you had to
resort to all that [__] talk
but if I had to choose and I do right
yeah you're contractually obligated yeah
gone to my head
she's really not cool you guys just let
me judge you won't get your fifty
dollars without it uh
for the weekend
um I have to go in
I just like the way Patrick Swayze
who s P's
used the last few seconds of his initial
argument to try to light his cigarette
what a great message for all the kids in
the audience
so I go with Dalton I have to go with
doll too
Dalton Dalton Andy signor
yeah there was one line that really got
me the best which was uh he Superman
looks like he's taking a ship but
Patrick Swayze looks like he took one 10
minutes ago
I can't I can't let that loose but then
you did Superman Man the Martha argument
at the end was really strong too you and
your [__] could knock someone down
I'm gonna go Superman
1-1 we're all tied up Mark andreco once
again this being Comic-Con lots of
people here could [__] and knock you
down
um as as much as I love Henry Cavill as
the screen junkies people know and the
government
it doesn't matter both of us we're not
we're not talking Mark loves all men
feminism what
um
Superman had a good argument but Dalton
after a really bad start I was like Wow
Joe didn't think he was going to make it
this far uh the uh taking a [__] I'm
relaxed and evacuating and Dad's jeans
that I just have to give it to Dalton
two one two one two one Dalton Ross Mark
wand
it's 2-1 Dalton deciding vote Marquand
game point Marquise you're the Ruth
Bader Ginsburg of this situation
do we have a drum roll
do it in slow motion
I'm gonna go with
man
or Dalton
[Music]
yeah
Comic Con spring junkies tournament in
nurse let's hear it for Mike Carlson
wow uh can we have a round of applause
for all of our Debaters tonight
folks if you're in Los Angeles you can
see the tournament in nurse the third
Saturday of every month at the UCB
theater
come on out yes how oh Andy
congratulations you guys on this whole
weekend it's been unbelievable big round
of applause for these guys and everybody
at screen junkies thank you all so much
for coming
um I want to thank Doug Benson Ross
Marquon Mark andreco Andy signor and I
just want to take a second
um to thank our Plus members because of
them were able to do this amazing thing
all weekend if you want to join and if
you want to join and enjoy nearly 20
weekly original shows and hours of live
content join right now at
screenjunkies.com plus and if you use
offer code SJ Central 16 you're gonna
get 50 off the annual membership it's
like we're giving it away our prices are
insane um it's the best deal we offer
all year so join screen junkies Plus
thank you for tuning in Andy anything to
add yeah you'll see a new show from Doug
Benson if you join plus yes
you guys thank you for spending part of
your Comic Con right here at SJ Central
thank you for watching at home bye see
you next year
difference
thanks again to Mafia 3 for sponsoring
this episode to watch our previous show
click the box to the left and to see
everything from screen junkie Central
click the box to the right
foreign